it's it makes you very angry
when you know that a problem you need
help
and you can't guess it
and ultimately
your family laughed without you
steve has every reason to be furious
he has terminal lung cancer
as a former cancer researcher and
paramedic steve knew he was very sick
but it took over six months for him to
convince his gp to see him i felt that i
was going to suffocate i felt i could
collapse at the side of the road it must
be
extremely frustrating
to not be listened to
i tried everything i ran out of options
when that gp will not say will not refer
repeatedly
over an eight-month period you have no
option
lie down here sir the nhs is now rolling
out one of its biggest lung cancer
diagnosis programs
mobile sites like this one are being
used to target at-risk communities
[Music]
14 years ago a scan like this one saved
manuela's life when it found a lump on
her breast
i was very
pleased very lucky they called me
because what happened on the path
is in my life before
the nhs says some 600 people have
already been diagnosed early by these
mobile clinics
certainly if we compare our survival
figures to the scandinavian countries it
looks as though we lose people
sooner uh when they have cancer than in
those places and mostly that's because
people are diagnosed at a point where
the cancer has spread further and is at
the so-called higher stage so i have one
box of these every month
steve doesn't know how long the drugs
will keep him alive
but he says
it would be longer
if his cancer had been found sooner
joshi sky news stoke on trent